So that was very astute of you.
And in fact there's a very general
property that could be stated about
learning algorithms of this type.
So if we have a learning update rule
like the one that we have, which is that
the value at time T is the value at
Time T minus one, plus some learning
rate times the difference between the
new estimate and the previous estimate.
Or the new observed value and
the previous estimate, then
this Vt will actually go
to the true expectations,
the actual average value of
the Rs once T is big enough.
Okay, so that's good.
That means it's actually
learning the right thing, but
there are conditions that we have to
put on the learning rate sequence.
And the learning rate sequence has to
have the property that if you sum up all
the learning rates,
it actually sums up to infinity.
It's unbounded.
it diverges.
>> As opposed to greater than infinity.
>> Oh, good point.
Yes, that it's equal to infinity.
Very good, it's actually
greater than any finite number.
Anyway, yeah it diverges, but
the square of the learning rates,
if you sum those up,
it's less than infinity.
And we're not going to get in
the details about why these
are the standard properties for
making this kind of learning rule work.
But the first approximation, the
learning rates have to be big enough so
that you can move to what the true
value is, no matter where you start.
But they can't be so big that
they don't damp out the noise and
actually do a proper job of averaging.
So, if you just accept that these
are the two conditions that make sure
that that's true,
that gives us a way of choosing
different kinds of
learning rate sequences.
>> Okay so what's some alphas that tease
to satisfy that and some that don't.